[Nathan]
Hey, John.
[Low self-esteem Nathan]
BOOOO.
[Nathan]
Hey John. So, the other day I was just walking down the
[Low self-esteem Nathan]
This intro is traaaash.
[Nathan]
This guy's always in here, just telling me I'm not good enough.
[Low self-esteem Nathan]
You look like- you look like Drake's ugly cousin, Derek.
[Nathan]
Can't argue with that.
I'm not good at a lot of things.  Most things, some would say. Here's a list of all the things I'm good at, versus
all the things I'm bad at.
I'm not good at sports, I don't know how to... make pottery. I can't juggle. I'd make a terrible doctor.
[Concerned Patient Nathan]
Just give it to me straight, doc. How is she?
[Doctor Nathan]
Well, if we're being honest, I don't think she's gonna make it.
[Concerned Patient Nathan]
No!
[Doctor Nathan]
If we're being really honest, your shoes are wack and you smell really bad.
[Concerned Patient Nathan]
What?
[Doctor Nathan]
Like, I could smell you when I walked into this room.
Like, maybe it's best if she died. So she won't ever have to smell you again.
[Concerned Patient Nathan]
What?
[Doctor Nathan]
Now, we're going to have to run a couple more tests to be sure, and it
-oh, never mind, she's dead.
[Nathan]
I can't do a good Kanye impression, but I can do a good impression of Obama doing a bad Kanye impression.
[Obama Kanye Nathan]
Now, Yeezy Yeezy Yeezy... uh, just jumped over jumpman.
Uh, Kim. Where you at, honey?
[Obama Kanye Nathan]
No, Michelle, jus- there's no Kim, it was just the video.
[Nathan]
But even with the things I think I AM good at, I always feel like I'm not good enough.
Like, there's always that tiny little voice in my head that's like:
[Tiny voice in Nathan's head Nathan]
You call that a good grade?
You call that being a good friend?
You call that a crème brûlée?
[Low self-esteem Nathan]
You call that a flashback?
[Nathan]
If you think I'm bad at this, then why don't you just leave?
[Low self-esteem Nathan]
No, I know you're bad. I just need you to know you're bad.
[Nathan]
My problem is, if I'm not amazing at something, I just tell myself, what's the point of even doing it?
Like, if I'm not an amazing singer, why sing at all? Why would anyone want to listen to me when they can listen
to Adele
to Adele, or
to Adele, or Shawn Mendes
to Adele, or Shawn Mendes, um...
to Adele, or Shawn Mendes, um, Crazy Frog?
The thing is, the only way you can be amazing at something is if you practice. But I don't want to be at
that first level, where I'm trash at it. I just hate feeling like the most unqualified person in the room.
Which is why I feel so uncomfortable in my... [game show noises] Guess which class it is, guess which class
it is... All of them. It's all of them.
I still vividly remember being a small kid in art class, and another kid, who was just sitting in front of me, out of nowhere just turns arounds and says,
[Another small kid Nathan]
Look at this poor, helpless fool trying to draw his measly giraffe, as I complete my replica of...
Café Terrace at Night by Vincent van Gogh. I wish death upon you and your family, yes, I hope you die.
Hahaha! Class, look at this, let's all laugh, haha! In unison. Hahaha!
[Nathan]
That was all probably in my head. What actually probably happened was he just turned around and said,
[Another small kid Nathan]
Oh Nathan, that looks pretty good.
[Nathan]
And then, I started thinking,
[Small kid Nathan]
That looks
Good?
He's lying.
He hates it.
He's taunting me.
I- I- I have to kill him before he kills me.
[Nathan]
I wish I had an answer for this problem of not feeling good enough, but, uh, I don't. Uh, it's something I go
through everyday, still. What I'm trying to do right now is just do things. Just do things I love,
regardless of how 'good' I am. And just not care. What's that quote?
[Nathan]
See, your life is like... rolling...
[Low self-esteem Nathan]
Oh boy, he's gonna try and make it a food metaphor!
[Nathan]
See, your life is like... rolling...
A burrito. You got all these things you're good at. You got your rice, you got your beans, you got the succulent
chicken. The lettuce, the sour cream, the guac.
If the money right.
Eating them separately, you might not have not have the best chicken in the world, or the greatest sour cream you
ever tasted. You might not be incredible at this, You might not be amazing at that, but roll them all together
to make you, and you got a pretty good burrito.
to make you, and you got a pretty good person.
Uh! Nailed it.
[Low self esteem Nathan]
[Nathan]
Oh, hey, he's gone. I guess I learned to overcome it. That's what you call a character arc, kids.
That's storytelling.
That's writing.
Get me on a show!
That's my time here. I hope you enjoyed that. For more food-based inspirational metaphors, follow me on my
YouTube.
YouTube or my Twitter.
I just noticed I'm wearing this, but this is very appropriate.
Uh, the cowardly dog, the cowardly human.